[Musique]
vous avez de la chance vous allez avoir
des des conseils et les conseils d'UD
Marzin qui est libraire à Plaisir
librairie plaisir de lire bonjour
bonjour Pat alors je dis oui vous avez
de la chance parce que vous êtes vous
êtes une libraire heureuse oui très
heureuse est passionné je rappelle que
voilà vous avez rouvert la première
librairie enfin librairie indépendante à
plaisir alors qu'il n'y en avait plus
depuis quelques années
malheureusement et vous avez beaucoup
d'activités dans cette libririe alors
vous allez nous proposer d'abord on va
parler d'un auteur que vous allez
recevoir je crois que c'est le 16
novembre dans la
librairie qui qui est Jennifer le
sieieur et puis puis vous êtes venu
parce que vous êtes très généreuse avec
beaucoup de conseils avec quelques et
même on va parler peut-être même déjà de
Noël puisque les les calandriers et les
livres de l'avant ça existe exactement
on peut déjà se les procurer alors euh
on commence par Jennifer leciur
peut-être tout fait alors Jennifer
leciur vient nous rencontré à la
librairie pour son dernier roman euh qui
est donc rosevallent l'espion à l'œuvre
paru aux éditions Robert Laffond il est
paru là juste avant le juste avant l'été
et en fait Jennifer leur a voulu donner
un petit peu
remettre rosevallent en avant puisque
c'est cette femme qui a réussi à sauver
des milliers d'œuvres à restituer des
milliers d'œuvres en fait de qui avaient
espoliés pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale à les rendre aux familles aux
descendants des des des Juifs qui
avaient espoliés pendant la la Seconde
Guerre mondiale et Jennifer leessur en
fait est une autrice qui est d'origine
plaisiroise elle ne vit plus à plaisir
mais elle est elle a passé toute son
enfance à à plaisir et d'ailleurs elle
avait fait un de ses précédents dans les
forsacin dans les bois noacin pardon aux
éditions to où elle parle justement du
du de la de la de la forêt de
plaisir exactement c'est un petit essai
sur l'importance de la des forêts et des
hommes comment ils interagissent l'un
l'un avec l'autre alors donc elle sera
chez vous le 16 novemb à quelle heure à
19h 19h c'estàd al vous fermez voilà et
donc vous parlez avec
elle de roseevallent he donc Val et mais
également de ses précédents puis qu'elle
a quand même reçu le concours de la
biographie pour sa pour sa biographie
sur Jack lon c'est une grande biographe
à l'origine he oui c'est une biographe
tout à fait et là c'est là c'est un
récit ou c'est un roman c'est un peu ça
se lit comme un roman ça se lit vraiment
comme un roman mais c'est très très
sourcé enfin elle a fait beaucoup
beaucoup de recherches on le on le sent
mais on ne le ressent pas à l'écriture à
la lecture ça se ça se lit mais vraiment
comme un roman comme un roman et donc le
16 novemb à plaisir de direit plais plis
à 19h cette rencontre c'est bien de
rencontrer aussi un auteur de pouvoir
parler avec échanger sur sur leur
processus créatif pour discuter un petit
peu voir comment viennent les les les
leur leur inspiration en fait absolument
voilà donc ça c'est le premier événement
alors ensuite on va passer à vos vos
coups de cœur voilà oui ce que j'ai
envie ce que j'avais envie de de
proposer des voilà exactement des beaux
livres alors on a un très très B album
sur Top Johnson qui est cette autrice
finlandaise qui est la maman de mouine
mouine le troll alors moi j'ai été
nourrie à mouine le troll quand j'étais
petite Lorna mon associé aussi a été
nourri à min le troll quand elle était
petite puisqueen plus sa maman est
finlandaise donc d'autant plus donc
c'est un petit clin d'œili je découvre
tout à fait ou ou oui non mais voilà moi
c'est c'est voilà c'est c'est c'est de
la mythologie scandinave on va dire
c'est vraiment des des des des récits
avec ce ce ce ce personnage un peu
rondord cette créature un peu ronde qui
n'existe pas qu'il arrive des tas
d'aventures et une petite une petite
héroïne un petit peu détestable la
petite MU qui vient toujours mettre
mettre le bazar dans dans dans dans le
dans le quotidien de de Mumin mais là ce
ne sont pas les aventures de mouin c'est
vraiment sur le processus créatif de
comment de de top Johnson voilà et et
et ça c'est c'est pas pour enfants alors
non celui-ci n'est pas pour enfants
c'est c'est un album qu'on peut offrir
justement à quelqu'un qui qui veut
découvrir ou qui est déjà voilà comment
comment est né mouine et comment comment
a écrit top Johnson donc voilà très joli
Liv aux éditions flamarion alors
celui-ci c'est un documentaire d'une
toute nouvelle maison d'édition les
éditions sont dessus dessous que je
voulais mettre un petit peu en avant
parce que c'est toujours quand voilà
quand on un nouveau un nouveau un nouvel
éditeur c'est il faut toujours les les
comment les les les mettre un petit peu
en avant et donc là ils nous ont fait un
histoire secrète d'animaux fantastiqu
moi j'aime beaucoup les illustrations un
petit peu un petit peu vintage comm ça
ou ou oui et donc on va avoir comme ça
le Kraken le comment tout
animx un petit peu bah la bête du
gévudan le monstre du
locnessesà réalités on ne sait pas trop
et donc on raconte voilà donc
dedans c'est toujours pas hein ah ben on
sait pas le mond encore MOS voilà on
parle aussi de la Licorne et du Yeti
mais bon donc huit animaux h animaux
légendaires dans cette dans cet album
redonner le nom de l'édition alors les
éditions sans dessus dessous sont dessus
dessous de vos mais non non mais c'est
c'est vraiment enfin moi j'aime beaucoup
en plus l'autrice Séverine Vidal est une
autrice une grande plume de la
littérature de jeunesse et elle écrit
très très bien alors celui-ci c'est
juste parce que c'est tout mignon voilà
l'amour sous toutes ses formes avec des
illustrations c'est un li à l'amour
parce que voilà l'amour est courageux
comme un petit panda qui part à la
découvert du monde ah c'est bien ça
voilà il peut avoir expressions et tout
ça et c'est juste pour dire aux autres
bah qu'on les aime c'est édition au
c'est quel âge oh ça c'est quasiment dès
la naissance on peut à N enfants tout
petit et puis et puis si on veut faire
cadeau à son fiancé à sa fiancé voilà
son son amoureuse son amour voilà on
peut tout à fait parce que ça c'est
vraiment un album touchouidou voilà
après la réédition une très très belle
réédition en intégral de la quête des
Willan de Pierre Botero euh avec un
jaspage ouais avec un jaspage absolument
magnifique c'est magnifique ça oui voilà
et donc la quête des Willan un grand
roman pour si si vous connaissez un
enfant ou même un adulte qui a adorer
Harry Potter vous pouvez lui offrir sans
problème il adorera aussi puisqu'on est
vraiment dans un univers aussi riche et
avec de la magie qui se fait par le
dessin et en fait Camille vit dans notre
monde et un jour en courant elle va
faire un pas de côté et glisser dans un
monde parallèle où elle va se découvrir
princesse au pouvoir
magique donc beaucoup de magie beaucoup
de beaucoup d'aventures et là c'est
l'intégral donc de la trilogie de la
quête des Willan et Pierre btero c'est
unà c'est unur frç c'est un grand auteur
français oui qui nous a malheureusement
quitté beaucoup trop tôt et qui nous a
laissé vraiment orphelin en littérature
de jeunesse et il inspire beaucoup ah
celui-ci c'est un objet collector pour
ah ouou c'est un très très bel objet
tout à fait et donc làon arrive vers
Noël oui déjà déjà on arrive de plus en
plus vite he vers ah oui oui oui oui je
vous confirme on a commencé à recevoir
nos calendriers de l'avant au mois de
septembre donc un peu surprenant on va
manger la galette dans peu de temps
exactement bientôt on l'aura au moment
de Noël bien avant et donc là je vous ai
apporté quelques petits bah pour
attendre Noël pour faire patienter en
attendant ça c'est bien parce que non d
c'est déjà on n'est pas obligé
d'attendre le 24 décembre pour faire ses
courses on peut anticiper un tout
anticiper et puis ça c'est c'est pour
faire patienter les enfants puisque
c'est un cal ah oui ça donc ça de toute
façon il faut l'acheter donc VO
exactement c'est le mois pour les
acheter c'est le mois de novembre et
donc on n'est pas obligé de manger des
chocolats tous les tous les jours on
peut faire autre chose et donc ce ce
petit calendrier de l'avant donc je vous
vous avez une petite une petite image de
comment de explicative en fait il va se
mettre en volume comme ceci et à
l'intérieur on va glisser une petite
bougie alors les petites chauff-plats
sans à l'aide hein vous savez vous
pouvez mettre et donc chaque jour on
ouvre ça s'allume et donc tous les jours
il va y avoir de plus en plus lum très
Jol voilà donc là celui-ci est laïque
mais il y en a également des religieux
qui existent sur le même principe après
on va avoir panda craft panda craft en
fait c'est un système voilà qui c'est un
abonnement normalement sur sur que vous
vous vous vous souscrivez pour votre
enfant et tous les mois vous recevez une
activité avec un petit livre et tout ça
et là il se ils sortent en librairie
maintenant des coffrets des coffrets
unique donc pas besoin d'abonnement et
euh vous pouvez là ils ont sorti donc la
boîte aux lettres de l'avant euh et donc
dedans vous allez avoir toute la petite
boîte aux lettres à créer à monter à
faire toutes les animations pour occuper
intelligemment les petites mains pendant
le mois de décembre en attendant Noël 24
jours
voilà 24 petites activités pour créer sa
boîte aux lettres de l'avant pour
envoyer la lettre au Père Noël et ça
c'est des enfants de quel âge à partir
de 3 ans c'est 3 7 ans eu 3 7 ans voilà
tout est marqué dessus ououi tout est
indiqué comme ça au moin ne se trompe
pas et alors c'est c'est la de année et
c'est très original ce sont les éditions
au zo qui font ceci des romans de
l'avant donc ça s'adresse à des un petit
peu plus grand là celui-ci sadresse à
des 10 et plus et donc chaque jour vous
allez ouvrir parce que c'est scellé tout
est scellé et donc comme à l'ancienne on
va prendre un coup de papier on va
ouvrir chaque jour on va ouvrir son
énigme du jour et donc oui on va avancer
dans le dans le dans l'enquête en fait
comme et tout ça et à la fin on aura
résolu l'enquête à Christmas City ah oui
oui non puis en plus c'est ça s'adresse
vraiment à des plus grands qui
n'auraient pas grand intérêt à un
calendrier de l'avant mais là pour le
coup voilà puis en plus c'est l'enquête
policière donc ça ça emmène toujours
puis en plus c'est génial pour apprendre
au fond à lire hein ah mais pour donner
envie de lire don Enie de lire chaque
jour et ça existe aussi pour un petit
peu plus jeune donc ils font aussi une
version pour pour les enfants à partir
de 8 ans ah c'est top et donc pour finir
une petite romance de Noël parce que
nous adultes aussi on a le droit de se
faire plaisir
B il y a des gens vous savez qu' sur les
chaînes il y a toujours des films de
Noël qui passent il y a des gens qui
sont fanatiques de ça et bien écoutez
maintenant nous avons les romance de
Noël également en roman donc là c'est
aux éditions Éloïse dormeson Nicolas
Barou une surprise de de Noël peut en
cacher une autre alors Nicolas Barot moi
c'est un auteur que j'aime beaucoup très
énigmatique puisqu'on ne sait pas qui
c'est euh il se cache derrière un pseudo
c'est traduit de l'allemand mais on en
sait pas beaucoup plus voilà on ne sait
pas on ne sait pas qui est ce qui est ce
monsieur mais il écrit c'est vraiment
traduit de l'allemand oui oui traduit de
l'allemand c'est marqué ici traduit de
l'allemand par Sabine Vicart féti ah
Nicolas Barot écrit dans allemand mais
exactement et donc et donc là vous allez
avoir une jeune fille une jeune femme
qui a une trentaine d'années elle est
considère un petit peu comme dans sa
famille très bourgeoise comme un petit
peu la raté puisqu'elle est traductrice
de finois et et là elle va recevoir deux
lettres au mois de novembre qui vont
chambouler complètement sa vie
puisqu'elle a une lettre de son éditeur
avec qui elle travaille depuis des
années qui annonce qu'il arrête
puisqu'il est malade et que la maison
d'édition est en train de péricliter et
la deuxième c'est qu'elle vient
d'hériter d'une péniche au cœur de Paris
donc tout voilà donc c'est c'est plein
de bons sentiments ça fait du bien c'est
oui c'est Noël voilà c'est Noël et puis
par les temps qui court ça fait du bien
peu douur mal oui un peu de un peu de
légèreté un peu de rêve exactement un
peu d'évasion oui c'est pas c'est pas
mal du tout tout à fait et ben merci
infiniment ah mais avec grand plaisir et
c'est donc aux éditions his d'ormon hein
c'est ça tout à fait euh merci et bravo
pour ce pour ces choix donc voilà oui
c'est vrai que oui le calendrier de
l'avant j'ai disais Noël mais j'ai c une
bétise 1 décembre donc donc on peut on
peut trouver ça et on peut trouver ça en
librairie c'est bien voilà voà et puis
je rappelle donc Jennifer leieur qui
sera le 16 novembre chez vous plaisir de
l à Plaisir euh qui est une auteur donc
qui a vécu à Plaisir euh et qui sera là
avec vous vous allez l'interroger les
gens pourront discuter avec elle voilà
il y a un petit pot après ah bah bien
entendu le verre de l'amitié comme
toujours avec modération merci
infiniment Marzin on se retrouvera parce
qu'il y aura on reparlera aussi de
cadeau à faire pour no s par j'aiit
unavant déjà
mais et tout à fait avec des très beaux
livres qui sont sortis aussi pour les
plus grands absolument merci infiniment
merci à
vous
[Musique]